-Thank you for coming back.
Last time, you came on the show
right before
"Black Panther:
Wakanda Forever."
-Yes.
-And I was like --
I had such a great time hanging
with you and talking with you.
-Yes.
-I'm like, "Let's have him back
after the movie comes out,"
just to see how you enjoy
being in one of the biggest...
-You missed me.
You missed me.
-I really do.
I mean, look at you,
by the way. Now a cover boy.
Oh, my gosh.
Look at this guy.
-Oh, boy. Oh, boy.
-"The Winston Duke Era
Begins Now."
-Oh, the Winston Duke effect,
you know?
-Yes, the effect.
-I'll take it.
-Last time --
Last time you came on, you --
You're obviously
very good-looking and tall,
but you're also very --
-Continue.
You should do a couple more.
-Thank you. Yeah.
You're very strong,
and you actually --
You put me in a full Nelson
and almost killed me.
And people seemed to enjoy that.
But, tonight, you have
a new feat of strength
and a talent,
a different talent...
-Oh, boy.
-...that you're gonna debut
involving an apple.
-Let's do it.
-Well, I mean, what --
First of all, how did you
figure out how to do this
and what are you going to do?
-You know, like
most hero origin stories...
[ Laughter ]
-My God.
-Like most hero origin stories,
it came out of need.
-Yeah.
-Great need.
A friend of mine...
-Mm-hmm.
-...was really hungry
in grad school,
and I had an apple,
but only one.
One apple.
-Wow.
-And I decided I needed to
share this apple really badly.
And somehow,
I summoned -- summoned!
-Wow.
-The strength to tear
this apple in half
so I could share it
with my friend,
a fellow actor
by the name of Mamoudou Athie.
-Wow.
-Yes.
-And so you did this --
-And I broke it.
Well, first, the key.
-Uh-huh.
-The key to the trick
is developing a bit
of a hand-hold space.
Right? So...
[ Crunch ]
Gentle bite.
-Wait. So you already
break the apple?
-Well, I was eating it.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, oh, so, your friend --
so your --
Oh, so your friend was --
-For the sake of accuracy,
I have to replicate the moment.
-Yes, I feel -- I feel you.
-So, I have a hand-hold.
-Oh, I see -- I understand.
-'Cause I need --
I need a space for the fingers.
-Yes.
-Ahh.
-Wow!
Ladies and gentlemen.
Wait! Whoa!
Wait, wait. Stop. Stop!
-Ah.
-It's too much!
-I'm doing it for the Roots!
-It's too much strength!
It's too much strength!
-I'm doing it for the Roots!
-Look at this. This is
the best thing I've ever seen.
Look at this.
How beautiful that looks.
Winston, this is a talent.
This is -- This is --
This doesn't end here.
This is going to go -- May I
have a piece of your apple?
-[ Laughs ] You can.
-Alright.
-That piece has no bite in it.
-Yeah.
Oh, it might have.
-It's still clean.
-And I washed my hands
before I came out.
-Winston Duke,
ladies and gentlemen.
That's what
I'm talking about here.
-You never knew
a true superhero...
-Could break an apple
into a thousand pieces.
...could break in apple in half.
Completely useless.
Late time you were here, you
were promoting "Black Panther."
We were talking about
what you're doing next.
You were going to the premiere.
-Mm-hmm.
-It didn't stop.
Have you had any time
to relax and enjoy yourself?
-Yeah, completely.
So, so much has changed,
you know, after doing
the Rihanna Fenty show.
-I mean, come on.
-You know? And --
-That's right!
-And having myself on the cover,
you know,
something that happened
that I didn't expect.
So all these big guys on Twitter
have now crowned me
the face of plus size,
of the plus-size movement.
-Is that right?
-I woke up one morning,
and I was plus size.
-It happens to --
It happens to a lot of people.
-I had no idea.
-Happens to a lot of people.
-You know?
And I became the face
of the plus-size movement.
You know,
I've been sharing my apples,
and now I'm the face
of the plus-size movement.
-Yeah, well,
that must feel good, though.
-Yeah. It felt great.
And then I went to Mexico,
and I went for, like,
a horseback ride,
like a little trail thing.
And this horse had no idea
that I was the face of the --
[ Laughter ]
the plus-size movement.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You know?
-No, he didn't know it at all.
-And this horse
was trying to play me, man.
This horse...
-He did not enjoy --
-...didn't want me on his back.
This horse
was throwing tantrums.
It was like --
[ Mimicking horse noises ]
-It looked back at you?
-It looked back at me,
exasperated.
-The guy's like,
"No, just, like, kick him,
and, like, he's just lazy.
He's lazy."
We got to a mild incline --
a mild incline.
And the horse stopped,
looked at me,
looked back at the incline,
and decided
it was not gonna go.
-Yeah. "Get off. Get off."
-The horse -- I was trying to --
Everyone was leaving me behind.
So I'm, like, trying to go fast.
We're finally getting back
after maybe like two hours
on this horse.
-Yeah.
-The horse finally sees home.
And that's the first time on
that trip that the horse ran.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah!
-The horse ran with, like --
With, like, maybe 20 feet left,
it sprinted.
I got off the horse.
And the horse literally
just started, like, shaking...
-You go, "Who are you?"
-It stopped, it turned around,
it looked at me...
-And said...
-...and just was like,
"You should know better."
And then walked in.
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-Walked away. It left.
You never saw the horse again.
-So this horse has no respect
for the thick thigh nation.
-Yeah, no, but --
-You know what I'm saying?
-Thick thigh nation.
-For thick thigh nation.
-He didn't know who he had on --
-Has no idea
that I'm the ambassador.
-Yes, you really are.
-You know?
-But now, I mean, look,
the movie
was not only number one.
It was number one for,
like, five weeks in a row.
-Five weeks, yes.
-I mean, you couldn't get a --
-It's also the top grossing
female-led superhero film
in the country.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And also --
can I just say, too,
after watching it, I loved it
and I thought
you were fantastic in it.
But, also, it's unlike
any Marvel movie in a way.
because I felt --
I felt like this one
was more emotional
than any of them have been.
-Yeah, you know, the first one
really caught everyone
off guard.
The first one,
no one knew what to expect.
And it became this beautiful
watershed moment
for everyone to kind of
recognize themselves.
And then it, you know,
of course, it would be
something hard to follow up.
And then we lost Chadwick,
and, you know,
the circumstance
became what it was.
And it became this opportunity
for us all to kind of come
to grips with the grief
that we've all been feeling.
-Yeah.
-And it became this opportunity
to say goodbye to Chadwick
and to give ourselves permission
to grieve.
The movie is about grief.
The movie is about, there's no
such thing as the right time.
There's no such thing
as the right way to grieve.
And the only way to do it
is to get through it.
And people really got a chance
to do that with the film.
So, it became
so much more -- again --
'Cause that was the thing.
It was like,
"How do we create something,
and not feel like we're trying
to replicate the first movie?"
-Yeah.
-And we found a way into it
by just embracing the truth
of the moment that we were in.
-That's what I'm talking about.
Bud, I'm so happy for you.
It couldn't happen to a nicer
guy. Congratulations.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Winston Duke
in "Black Panther:
Wakanda Forever."
Take a look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The river border
has been breached, huh?
If my soldiers were present,
this fish-man would be bound
before us as we speak.
-If your muscle brains
were present,
they would still be there
choking on their
fuzzy adornments.
-You bald-headed demon.
-Show some respect, you two.
-Respect? These men should be
ashamed to show their faces!
-Watch your tone, Jabari.
[ Affronted chanting ]
-Hey!
[ Spears clanking ]
[ Crunch ]
-Yeah!
That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Before -- Before you go,
I was wondering if you could
teach us the Jabari chant.
-Oh, man. Do you guys
want to learn the chant?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean --
Come on. Only you --
-Okay. Alright.
-Only you. The one and only.
Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow! Okay.
That's what I'm talking about.
Alright.
-We like giving the people
what they want.
-Yes, you have to give the
people what they want. Okay.
-So, when I say "meri ha"...
-Yes!
-That's a word that translates
to "win them."
-Yeah.
-You're going to say, "Ya."
I'm gonna grunt. Right?
That's the --
The gorilla tribe's grunt.
"Ooh."
You just repeat "ooh."
So, I say, "Meri ha,"
you say, "Ya."
-Ya.
-I say, "ooh."
-Audience: Ooh.
-Meri ha!
-Audience: Ya!
-Ooh!
-Audience: Ooh!
-Meri ha!
-Audience: Ya!
-Ooh!
-Audience: Ooh!
[ Repeated chanting ]
[ Drum beating ]
-Winston Duke, everybody!
"Black Panther:
Wakanda Forever"
comes to Disney Plus
February 1st.
Available on DVD
and Blu-Ray soon.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."